sai che richiamando levante e va bene se
non ci fossero questi [ __ ] merda
arrivate vidal cazzo bravi schiacciare
noi tutti lasciati la super lft ragazzi
e benvenuti mi sono video sono fa vj e
oggi sono con il qui presente sasha
anche detto anima anche detto pisellone
animo comprato le le sfere del drago e
lo perde adesso se non usate sono di
marijuana come fai a sapere di che cosa
sarà marijuana
noi dobbiamo dimostrare al mondo che ce
l'abbiamo più lungo di loro in questo
risotto giallo bravissimo a tutti chiami
fa vj non può mica perché c'erano che
scava vj proseguì sono linee mi trovi
sono di colore bianco e rosa pisellone
animate trovato io sono grossi
simoncelli 6 dormire ma perché io sono
grosso di a prescindere ma io ti stavo
aspettando dicendo beh io ti voglio
abbracciare vieni qui che di chico
pisellone anima hero va bene nome
dell'anno io ce l'ha la skin strana tu
mi vedi valore francese avevo già
piangendo dato suo decimo in classifica
io sono entrate vastaso già decimo
facciamo che io sono tu serpent a
comando che uccida questo come verde mi
sta antipatico si no io sei tutto
formarsi ars amando facebook o cade le
direbbe che è stato davvero molto
va bene che figura di merda
uno che non ci sono fortissimi torni
qualche sei di nuovo enorme
no sono doppi ma lasciamo nonno io ecco
ti fa nomi sotto tutto grosso del 26
sono questo puntino di minchia aspetta
che non ci riesco ecco mai gruppo a
quello grosso sono veramente grosso se
ti sto per proporre una cosa bruttissima
ma se dietro il mio culo e io ti premia
i figli punti crediti si sa nella foga
di uccidere persone spero di non uscire
artisiti vedo attenzione che ti stanno
circondando in 600 a caso è vero
tensione attenzione sei pazzo ma non ci
credo sono uniti
nota di merda facciamo che va bene
pietro dove sei morto non l'ho visto
richiamando levante e va bene eccoti
eccoti pisolo neanche sono io è morta
una tetta non morire ha detto legate
no non hanno nessun aggregata bible si
legge ho visto partire male in sé gelato
il sangue
il grosso occhio civico 1 gravissimo
grazie grazie di tecniche di chiusura
professor parlamento come siamo uguali
grandi quali più o meno
chiudi questo qua torna aspetta torna a
kg non ho questo 4 che so che ho capito
ho capito ho capito ma intanto escono
tutti del tu che cazzo logico questo
gioco di merda tirato malissimo ma dai
ma che cade se non sapevo come
comportarmi
ti sei preso i miei punti almeno sì la
metà si lamenta sì che ci riesco mi
aveva lavato e la madonna sta facendo
tutto da solo oggi ho chiuso uno stress
ma volo schiacciato questo l'ha visto
contro di me te ne sei accorto ha detto
ci sono riuscita 9 martino di verme a
un'orgia di vermi ammazza quelli dentro
poi ti libero e tattiche massa le stiamo
facendo è bene il senso io io li ingloba
ecco vedi le attenzioni che ci stanno
incastrando e facciamo un po più liberi
ed io seguo te va bene va bene dai 1 il
perché
cosa vuoi che piano però solo nono
adesso va beh io sono qui intimo in
classifica forse anche primo quasi che
questo volevo uccidermi a tutti i costi
che sei grande quanto una caccola ok
sono quarto dio mio mal primo quanti
punti st 21 mila ma quando ci arriva ma
possiamo fare è morto no come mi sono
salvato eccoti pisellone anima sono
dietro di te in cui inchiappetta non
chiudi occhio gli ho chiuso a voi due
die e arena questa è la rena io tifo per
te sento sempre l'ansia dove gli stringo
ancora di più dai visti st vantaggiato
gli sto rompendo più il cazzo a lui ed
ecco infatti è morto city sto mangiando
la cacca tipo gianni morandi ciao gianni
ciao gianni un abbraccio il profumo
della vita di merda lavo se non ci
passano questi [ __ ]
lerda elevate vidal cazzo di gara buona
se non ci fossero stati i deficienti era
buonissima quelli piccoli vedono tutti i
giganteschi brutto stronzo o bravo e
grazie aiuto ho visto laschi l'inter non
lo so c'è gente che sta implodendo
ma dopo attenzione agli me l'ho ucciso
io non è morto non muore ogni volta
dipende grandissimo viti aviazione
bailetti ho chiuso dentro ciò chiuso
dentro l'altro perfetto mi sento tutto
abbracciato tutto caldo grazie mamma che
mi abbracci a te jc 6 nov allora ti
scappa scattata la mischia che ora sto
sudando freddo l'hai ucciso tu sei forte
ero a rifredi tutti non lo so come ho
fatto ma va bene così l'hai ucciso tu
mica segno rido sopra di te ci sono io
resto qua o che qua è morto questo
perché sono scemo
scherzino ecco ti sei tutto grossissimo
papa degan
porca vacca papa venga allora che qua ce
n'è uno di qua sopra diversi che la
testa guarda guarda che ti lascio non
oggi al giro di arca vita c'è un lungo
articolo
buccino ha mangiato il pe ha mangiato il
peggio ucciso uno tutto grosso
ma non voglio provare primo che voglio
che le coppie a 306 cv ho capito quindi
sono io quello che deve arrivare in
classifica in questo vento per far
realizzare il sogno di più perché ho
capito tu ti dò io adesso appena
superato uno che si chiama cazzo moscio
quindi ce la posso fare tutte le chiudo
2 per kg due approcci doroteo spetta di
cicli dentro e guerra è guerra aperta
e guerra la rai guerra brutto stronzo
veicola sfida al senso va bene si è
suicidato non ha retto la sfida di
mortacci mia o ma come cazzo si fa
essere visi deficiente a questo karma
con ubriaco morto o di altre auto
stefani passa giocando stai veramente o
un'area look non lo so può essere che
non c'era un po di roba
però mi sa che mi hanno sono forse
riesco a chiuderli siamo gigante ci sono
gigante arrivo veramente si così a meno
inizia a prendere punti il primo 6 primo
nome sulla prima o poi devi entrare
anche tu adesso come facendo dio mio dio
ti aspetto a fini
vabbè grandissimo bravo così punti forti
ok mila a 3.000 punti guerra grandissima
fortuna
questa che sta inglobando uno che sono
il globo vinto la vita non si lascerà
mai andare grandissimo fatto un'azione
incredibile sei lezioni grandissimo
oddio se sopravvivo a questa cosa qua ho
fatto sono in classifica sono xi
fantascienza isri al siamo tutti e tre
classificati sta avendo male alcune
troviamoci concludiamo il video sono
giovani grande
giusto così bene se ammazzo questo
finiamo che io sono dentro di te non
potevamo concludere mi sta un video
meglio di così classifica tutti e due
ragazzi ciao proprio misto ma non crepa
che sta succedendo o ansia stringe
sempre di più stringo sempre di più
sembra una cosa porno sì ma non
ammalarsi lips e moriva all'inizio se si
faceva il personaggio a questo era di
uno così grosso porca l'accaduto esiste
ma guarda che che imperterrita avanti
perché non tutte le ciambelle escono col
buco
ti lascio ti l'aspettava avere spiaggia
a questo punto io sono ottavo lui e
prima c'è ma anche cup che situazione è
stata la partita più bella della storia
della vita di slitte rio ragazzi 100.000
cena o per forza ci vai avanti o
sfondare il tasto mi piace c'è cos'è
così facendo 100 mila mi piace
bellissimo ragazzi io con quello che
l'episodio ringrazio sasha per aver
partecipato a questo video quindi
ragazzi conclude l'episodio spero che
video vi sia piaciuto ringrazio sasha
per questa incredibile cosa che abbiamo
appena fatto che non so neanche
descrivere però che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi 100.000 laica assolutamente dopo
l'arresto 6 vita è piaciuta cosa
interessante è un mi piace ai capace di
facebook e come lo invito a trattare
descrizione sostenersi discutere ci
vediamo al prossimo video vi stava
ammazzando il telecomando ma aspetta
l'uso anch'io
beh ragazzi